[Music]
the main thing people think about pop is
you go on to Compton and everybody's
gangbang and I used to shooting at you
but it's really not like that there have
been times that people made rude
comments while we were at a competition
one of the girls has been oh there's
some Compton we probably have bullet
holes in their barn or something so
right for comes if it comes a sense of
pride my name is Sheila
oh yes vessel I'm 17 years old and I'm a
student at the computer Buffy a program
that keeps kids on horses and off the
street looks great
bend your knee though can do you see
this make sure you sort of have your
ears double your shoulder down to here
all in line I've been riding with the
coffee here posse for about six years
now I am one of the more experienced
riders in the program I have learned a
lot about myself I definitely have more
patience after working with horses like
when I first started riding I like
eleven years old I just always get in
trouble from like attitudes problems you
come in with the bad attitude when
you're trying to ride a horse and it
comes out through them too like you're
in sync with yours when you're supposed
to be in sync it's a partnership
you do have serious competitors at the
configure epoxy we talk to a show per
month just to show what kind of progress
that we've been doing and what kind of
we're continuing with the kids
we're coming out there and competing
with the upper level of people I came in
fourth where the metal finals at the
interest elastica question League
competition that's a big deal it is a
karyotype set more people in the horse
world are white and rich but there are
more people from different backgrounds
and different demographics that are
competing now those good spreads the
stereotype
[Music]
you
[Music]